19h la candidate de la république en
marche arrive sur la pointe des pieds
fanette chervier n'en est pas sûr mais
elle vient de battre la députée sortante
barbara romagnan j'ai quelques résultats
mais c'est vraiment pas représentatif
c'est certes quelques quelques bureaux
de vote qui remonte au fur à mesure donc
pour l'instant je préfère attendre les
résultats définitifs pour commenter les
résultats lui sont favorables aux
périphéries beaucoup moins sur besançon
pendant quelques minutes les 14 points
d'avance du premier tour semble loin
finalement c'est chez nos confrères de
france bleu qu'elle a la confirmation de
sa victoire c'est définitif c'est
officiel c'est la première élection en
tant que député de fanette charvier avec
un score de 53 49 % devant barbara
romagnan c'est un résultat effectivement
sérémé
mais voilà c'est tout cas c'est c'est
tout de même la légitimité des urnes qui
parlent ce soir barbara romagnan avait
prévenu ce deuxième tour devait remettre
les compteurs à zéro
elle qui avait finalement obtenu le
soutien de jean luc mélenchon dans
l'entre-deux-tours échoue en larmes
après un seul mandat
je suis déçu évidemment pour tous ceux
qui sont là qui sont beaucoup beaucoup
mobilisé ne mangera merci beaucoup et
puis voilà je suis inquiète de ce qui se
passe j'espère que tous les députés qui
sont là qui sont bien des députés
autonome la loi qui sera le travail qui
se prépare vraiment très inquiétant
fanette charvier poids plume de la
politique parfaitement inconnus des
électeurs il y a quelques semaines
encore devient à 32 ans la plus jeune
député du doubs